[Music]
my son Michael is a big sports fan he
just met Tom Brady but my youngest son
Brendan is a huge rock fan and Dwayne
and I did a movie called pain and game
together he's actually shooting a pilot
right now for me Miami called ballers
with Pete Berg directing who directed
lone survivor but he was nice enough to
come over to my trailer my son's came to
visit and my son's playing really shy
and he's like trying to lure them out of
the bathroom you know the rock is a nice
guy really nice guy he brought all these
toys and all this stuff from the WWF he
just fought for the championship and so
he's like come on out guys don't be shy
I'm cool you know and then you know he
gives my one son a high five then he
goes to shake my other hand my younger
son's hand and he slips the hand shaker
punched him square in the nuts
square in the nuts and he had a big you
know it's not cool cuz I'm like dude why
you swear did your son learn to do this
defeat I don't know I guess it's in the
genes or so but uh but yeah Dwayne just
looked at me like I said dude I didn't
it was like he was gonna hit me in her
turn yeah the four year olds he's gonna
punch me in the face but but I he took
it like a man
don't I own the rock if you call
yourself the rock you have to be cool
with yeah kids hitting you in the nuts